[Music]
thank you
millions of people that are going to ask
you why you think that they've done
wrong and they're going to come and say
to you good luck to you right now
I think that's right yeah instead of
telling young people know
do whatever you can like do not give up
work on it like what his grandma said
like you got to do whatever it takes not
just to stay married but to stay in a
healthy marriage I mean not like staying
and arguing yeah I don't break up
because of my daughter because I didn't
want her to see the arguments but Pearl
just here
okay
that's more of a traditional thing to
stay together
oh she's too drunk She's Gotta Go no I'm
not drunk you talking about you are
taking drugs
put your hands on me it's time to go I'm
saying to you boy thank you
go get your phone
what's going on Ellen didn't do anything
to you I was scared
what's going on
[Music]
oh my God
Gin and Juice boy
kids study school stuff Simon it's okay
just come out
you can't really go down
you put your hands on me I'm getting the
face down no you're being prosecuted
right now
right now can't tell me what I'm doing I
want my stuff
come on do it
yeah
exit is this way
right
now
I just said to her calm down yeah you
said it straight still I heard that and
then she tried that now but I'm not
upset and then yeah but and then she
goes I know you're the real one I know
you're the real one yeah she's been
trying to Rattle people's kids from the
start you know
I hate that guy you know I just can't be
bothered anymore okay all right I think
the show starts out early yeah let's go
let's go let's have fun you can finally
get the answers to some people will give
up for social media or for their
relationships
there's a virtue by the way
oh Lord you got a dangerous smile you
gotta stop smiling over here
it's a bit shiny but yeah I like it I'm
hating the camera now why I need a hat
man look at my forehead listening now
you do it all right brother yeah
apparently Clips I was scared she's
still talking
can you please sir
you know
uh this is gonna be a YouTube short I'm
sorry I'm backstage Matthew said it was
going to go viral today hey you guys
like And subscribe yeah have you heard
this experience
level four on the patreon
oh
wow guys she's not from London by the
way she's from Manchester this is what
happened the Manchester Madness yeah
trust
I'll just close up the door man yeah
this is mine thank you you just be
afraid about random bags in there yeah
oh boy
[Music]
shambles that great belongs
you're nearly a half a decade
literally she's the oldest one here but
that's what I had a feeling I had a
feeling she was like Hey listen you hold
your nerve you know I'll be real I was
like I thought you were gonna get around
much sooner but yeah
the show is called just pearly things
not just so much for things no guys I
have to go give a police statement so um
we'll miss you I have to go give a
police statement so I'm gonna let you
out for a second oh wow okay
this is um this is King Rich's he's um
he's um one of the most talented hello
um um he he has a show anyways what
we're talking about what would you give
up for the right guy oh that works
what's going on people
so so where did where am I picking up
like what was the current conversation
[Music]
isn't it in a position where you can get
in trouble
sounds all right enjoy the rest of your
life thank you very much